For the first one we just have p to the 3 5ths, power divided by root or the
index. For the second one we'll have the quantity of 3, 2 to the 4th raised to
the 1, 6th. The power of this radican is really a 1, so we have our power of 1
divided by our index, our root, which is 6. For the third one we'll have the
quantity 5x squared raised to the 1 3rd power. We're taking the cubed root of
this expression, and again we don't use the 2 as a power because the square is
not the power of the 5 as well. It's only the power of the x. We have this
quantity raised to the 1, so there's our power and then the 3 or the cube for
our root. And for out last one we have 25 x squared raised to the one third
power. We have power divided by a root. You might have simplified this, which
is great. We could have rewritten 25 x squared as the quantity 5x squared.
Then, since we're raising a power to a power we can multiply 2 times 1 3rd.
This would give us 5x raised to the 2 3rds, another acceptable answer. Great
work if you got at least two of those correct. I know these were pretty tricky.